[Musique]
enfin les enfants bof
oui ce monsieur avec une casquette ces
nounours pas trop pour jouer de
l'accordéon
il faut mettre une casquette et des
rouflaquettes ce le plus amusant
amuse-toi bien nounours mais soit
raisonnable taki tesi patrons
dont les seuls
[Musique]
au soir les enfants
ouais mon accordéon
[Musique]
n'ont pas de blague j'avais laissé mon
accordéon sur la table où est il
nicolas oula tu me jeta sur nous que je
n'ai pas vu et moi péno s'il est perdu
vous verrez la colère de nounours pomme
cherche mais il est peut-être sous la
table sous la table voyons
oh comme
le voilà mon cher astronomes en bugey
music hall où nick ne nous
[Musique]
et
bravo no more que tu joues bien et à la
je suis doué
à l'eau on lui à présent orly talonne à
la critique
on à gauche un autre
tu peux laisser ton accordéon deux noms
que l'on porte petite coquine je vais
charme et mon cher patron avec de la
vraie musique
on dormait vous vite
[Musique]
badri denos
petit frère pour être grande soeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
te voilà
accordéoniste alors patron que je touche
vous joue un petit lingot jugera va non
merci nounours il ne faut pas faire de
bruit les enfants dorment déjà sevrin
[Musique]
aux eaux
bonnes nuits des enfants feu de pur
[Musique]
e
oh
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]